في بلدتين نورداغ واصلاحيه بولايه غازي
عنتاب بدات شركه الاسكان التركيه المعروفه
اختصارا باسم توكي عمليات اعاده اعمار
المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال
العمليه بدات هنا ببناء
855 وحده سكنيه في المنطقه ومن المتوقع
تسليمها لاصحابها في غضون سته اشهر
السلطات التركيه قالت انها ستبني 272 الف
وحده سكنيه في 11 ولايه خلال عام واحد ضمن
مناطق بعيده عن خطوط الصدى وبمواصفات
تناسب الطراز المعماري لهذه المناطق
وبشروط موافقه لشروط السلامه من الزلازل
بحيث لا يتجاوز عدد طوابق البناء الواحد
اربعه طوابق كما سيتم بناء الاف المنازل
الريفيه في القرى التي تضررت من الزلزال
بالتوازي مع عمليات اعاده الاعمار هذه
تواصل السلطات بناء مساكن مؤقته بدلا من
الخيام في مئه وثلاثين منطقه ضمن الولايات
المتضرره من الزلزال
من بلده نورداغ في ولايه غازي عنتاب زيدان
زنجلو